so we got around this three times and
you can see the way it works and you'll
get a bit more of a live work because
you have seen these before right first
we're going to go once you if you go
then two then three because we want
increasing amounts of detail so if I
want one significant deal which out of
the six digits has been put there which
is the most important number it's gotta
be that turn right it's gotta be the two
it's the it's the biggest number because
even though two is smaller than nine we
have a place value system so that two
really stands for
two hundred thousand okay so the most
significant figure there is going to be
the first one you see so maybe you want
to highlight it that's the most
important number okay so then I think
about well all of these other numbers
that are gonna get me run it away right
do they leave me towards going up to the
next number up or coming down and
staying what it is right and you can see
because the next number is am nine this
number is clearly closer to 300,000
right it's easy to check because if you
try the other alternative 200,000 you're
19 3568 away whereas here you're only
6,000 and some change
that's a much much smaller as a gap so
make sense so again I'm looking at
follow-up one significant figure it's
just the first number that I'm basing
this off okay make sense let's do just
introduced its having to do
okay again instead of looking at only
just the one most important number I
look at that two most important ones
which in this case are the two of the
nine right so I'm going to expand the
two and the nine of most important
numbers so then I think either other
numbers that are left over go to make me
round up or stay at two and no okay and
I'm going to say because I look at the
next number which is three so that
rather these are the familiar rules of
roundings that we've seen before
okay the more important bit is thinking
about which numbers are going to stay or
change and the other bit I think is
quite straightforward
so like you said to die those are the
two significant figures and everything
else turns into zeros okay again easy to
check if you've went up to 300,000
you're further away see this number is
further away then this one this one is
closer so more significant figures more
accuracy one last them
okay are you getting sick of my hat now
which numbers am I gonna look at the
first three because they had the biggest
three in our place value system it's two
hundred thousand nine thousand three
thousand they're all much bigger than
the five six and eight that I have left
okay so after you settled that these
three of you want
what are they closer to going up or stay
put where they are they're gonna go up
one thing so when I round to three
significant figures it looks like when
we go up to two hundred ninety-four
thousand okay so random done and again
like a check because if I compare that
to if I pick the other option 293,000
that's gonna be further away than the
option I arrange it you can always check
you never need to be any job it's really
easy you just you can even get your
calculator and actually subtract them
and see which one it's Squaresoft okay
again we're gonna go once you hear two
and three okay so I'm going to ask the
same question I did before in this new
number which is really really tight okay
which is the most important the most
significant number
it's gonna be the seven right like this
is the biggest actual number because
again in our place value system the
further it is to the left
the bigger the actual number is so this
number is like more than ten times
bigger than the next number so it's more
important to me okay so then I think
join you to go up to the other numbers
tell me to go up or my question I should
staying where I am
I should go up so for one significant
figure this is equal to 0.08 okay and
you might have some questions if you've
written down some answers let's see if
we can tackle this together we'll do it
be quick up to significant figures I'm
looking at the seven in the six the next
immediate number after that is uh zero
so that's going to told me to go down
yeah so I'm gonna write that at zero
point zero seven six
again you can see people compare that
you see
yeah that's a great question okay so the
short answer is no but let's actually
understand why okay
so in case you didn't quite catch that
Sandy's wondering tell me if I'm wrong
there like hey I already did this this
is already an eight so shouldn't this
let me start with an eight and the
answer is no because here's why
why don't think about once an even go
Justinian is three I mean I've sort of
done something a bit weird by stringing
these questions all together right for
us we usually say look I just
just tell me one number accuracy
whatever is the most appropriate I
didn't need to know it at three
different levels we're just kind of used
to practice the skill
so therefore this question it kind of
sits on its own you want your now
investigating this number with nothing
else in the picture and you want to say
okay if I can only keep two numbers and
I want to be as close as possible to
this one then I can keep seven and six
there's no reason why not I don't have
to change it up to an eight because
that's gonna make me further away like
if I had retained that maybe if I'd be
easier point zero eight zero right like
that's the smallest zero it's something
that I could have now it's still a lot
further away from this number then this
is yes are always gonna treat it as a
new question and get as close as I can
now that thing will use the last one
what you get 0.06
here now this is interesting just a
keyboard because what we look to all
these are the questions and this is kind
of like a rule the people wanna remember
right it's like look zeros and zeros
zeros and zeros and all of them all the
ones I underlined were insignificant but
in matter they weren't part of the
accuracy but you guys put this one here
right now see that zero then and it's
exactly the same as this is you're here
it matters how do I know that it matters
it comes off so the first thing you
notice is well I just want the three
most important numbers and they happen
to be a seven and a six and A zero in
the same way that for my class it
happened to be a three and a zero
like don't be discreet at sea row he's
an important number two he can be
washing well you look at this right I
actually can look at this now and I can
know because you told me this here is he
knew I didn't know what this number
actually stands for like if it's a what
information tells when I worked on this
on problems
I actually stated I told you right so if
I came over here and I said there are
thirty students to two significant thank
you isn't that big Ewing anymore is that
right so obviously the zero matters
because you said that it matters and
here if you write this down and you say
if you put this that's you signalling to
me hey that zero is not rounded that's
your own matters it came from something
in the original number okay so the
easiest way to know it and now I'm going
into like a course examiner now if you
want to know like for how do I judge you
look at what it says and if you're
writing the answer you should tell me to
just write this number and leave me to
guess tell me how many scenic views you
intended support
the question I'll ask you around okay
yeah the question the question we'll ask
and if you're if it's the other way
round then it's you're responsible as a
student like I'm I'm wanting to
communicate I write this number down I
want you to know that I knew what this
number came from and so I'm writing
three significant figures no no you
can't know information
I can't assume that significant I have
to assume it's not okay because because
without any information without me
telling me how many you've actually
placed there's one or two positives
either it is significant or it was the
result of rounding but I don't know
which one it is some kind of students it
matters